[Música]
hola vivimos en un planeta azul quizás
esto fue lo que me motivó a que desde
muy pequeñita con tan solo 6 años me
enamoré del mar y decidí que quería ser
bióloga marina
quizás fue una sorpresa para mi padre
sabiendo que yo había nacido en una
región de los llanos venezolanos y
quizás fue un viaje que hice a galicia
con solo dos años esa inmensidad del mar
lo que me resultó atractivo y llevó a
que toda mi carrera tanto formación
hiciera vio la biología marina como
también después toda mi carrera
profesional la dedicará con todos los
esfuerzos a estudiar el mar y ver las
las potencialidades que tenía eso
terminó llevando mi carrera profesional
a ser en estos momentos la considera del
mar de la xunta de galicia no puede no
puedo olvidar que en estos momentos
todos somos conscientes que estamos
viviendo una situación de cambio
climático una situación que nos está
llevando a ver con miedo nuestro futuro
yo siempre digo que la única derrota que
podemos asumir es aquella batalla que no
damos y por lo tanto ante esta situación
de cambio climático los biólogos marinos
y las personas que nos dedicamos a
gestionar las políticas del mar
tenemos que tener en cuenta que el
futuro de la humanidad tanto la que vive
más pegada a tierra como la que vive con
los ojos puestos en el mar necesita dar
pasos para seguir avanzando en ese
futuro que todos necesitamos si nos
quedamos quietos desde luego el cambio
climático nos llevará por delante pero
todos podemos poner de nuestra mano para
cambiar las políticas pesqueras para
cambiar las políticas de las acciones
que hay que hacer sobre el mar y
conseguir que ese cambio climático se
transforme en una nueva potencialidad
que nos dé mucho futuro a toda la
humanidad a veces cuando hablamos del
mar
muchos tendemos a pensar que solamente
le afecta a las personas que viven cerca
de la costa o aquellas que desarrollan
su actividad profesional vinculada con
algunas de las actividades que se
desarrollan en el mar esto no es así
tenemos que ser todos conscientes que
toda la contaminación que todos los
actos que hacemos cada día terminan en
el mar y que ese terminar en el mar
puede significar acabar con la vida
marítima y por supuesto con la vida
terrestre
tenemos que dar esos pasos de futuro
nosotros tenemos muchísimas experiencias
hemos sufrido pues contaminaciones como
fueron las del prestige que fue un hecho
conocido a nivel mundial en aquellos
momentos los más pesimistas entendían
que la vida en el mar se había
finalizado que la galicia pesquera había
desaparecido y que por lo tanto una vía
negra se nos afrontaba sobre nuestro
futuro no nos quedamos quietos abordamos
la necesidad de cambio abordamos unas
políticas pesqueras que mejoraron la
gestión y que conseguimos mejorar que
esa contaminación en tan sólo seis meses
diera unos resultados de futuro eso nos
debe de servir de ejemplo para todo lo
que tenemos que hacer a partir de ahora
estamos viendo los que nos dedicamos a
las políticas pesqueras como
determinadas especies van cambiando su
ubicación es decir en estos momentos en
las aguas del norte somos capaces de
encontrar especies que nunca existieron
aquí por lo tanto esto también debe de
llevarnos a cambiar esas
disponibilidades de estas nuevas
especies
y buscarlas como alimento para la
humanidad que tenemos que hacer pues por
lo pronto buscar cómo las nuevas
tecnologías pueden afectar también está
disponibilidad de acceso a nuevos
caladeros como las diferentes
actividades que se desarrollan en el mar
pueden impactar en esa gestión pesquera
cada vez más estamos buscando energías
renovables energías que contribuyan a la
descarbonización energías que
contribuyan a que la contaminación en el
mundo marítimo y en el mundo terrestre
sea menor pero esas búsquedas de
energías renovables también están
buscando espacio para competir con las
zonas de pesca por lo tanto es necesario
estudiar el territorio estudiar los
bancos de pesca estudiar el movimiento
de las especies buscar las ubicaciones
para que esas energías renovables las
podamos obtener del mar pero sin
impactar en todo aquello que supone una
fuente de alimento y una fuente de
riqueza yo siempre digo la necesidad
busca el cambio y ese cambio viene
porque toda la humanidad
la mente digo los que viven en las zonas
pesqueras sino todos seamos conscientes
de que ese mar azul debe de seguir
siendo azul y para ello la
industrialización que estamos haciendo
tiene que empezar a cambiar el rumbo
tenemos que ser conscientes de que todos
esos plásticos todas esas basuras que
estamos generando de alguna manera están
colapsando en el planeta y ese colapso
puede llevar a la destrucción de la vida
y por lo tanto nosotros tenemos ser
conscientes que solamente unas políticas
serias unas políticas que busquen nuevas
vías de financiación unas políticas que
busquen más interrelación entre todas
las regiones unas políticas que
contribuyan a conocernos más de manera
internacional a que seamos capaces de
interaccionar serán capaces de que
sigamos teniendo un mar que sea
productor de energía productor de
alimentos y productor de vida para todos
los demás es por lo tanto necesario que
siempre los que nos dedicamos a estudiar
el mundo del mar tengamos en cuenta que
la explotación del mar
debe de hacerse desde tres principios el
aspecto medioambiental el aspecto social
y el aspecto económico en galicia
tenemos muchos ejemplos pero a mí uno
que me gustaría destacar sobre todo los
demás y es el aprovechamiento de los
bancos naturales por parte de un
colectivo que aquí denominamos
mariscadoras estas mujeres son
profesionales que se dedican a la
recolección de moluscos bivalvos y que
aprovechan no sólo la producción natural
sino que con sus trabajos contribuyen a
incrementar la producción de estos
propios bancos naturales es decir
haciendo unas labores de acuicultura o
de semi cultivo son capaces de recuperar
la producción natural que el propio mar
nos da y hacer de ello una profesión
nosotros en un momento determinado de la
historia hemos hablado con este
colectivo de profesionales que se
dedicaban única y exclusivamente a
realizar labores extractivas y les hemos
dicho si queréis contribuir a mejorar
vuestra profesión vuestro futuro aquí
se mar cada vez sea más productivo
necesitamos adoptar medidas que permitan
mejorar esa producción natural y eso lo
podemos hacer con unas pequeñas labores
de semi cultivo es decir limpiar las
zonas de trabajo sembrar en las zonas
donde todavía no había producción y
realizar una comercialización solamente
de aquellos moluscos que ya han
contribuido a la reproducción de sus
bancos y por lo tanto podremos mantener
siempre una producción estable nosotros
le hemos puesto el modelo de gestión y
ellas fueron capaces de [ __ ] ese tren
ese tren que han cogido las mariscadoras
en galicia que ha permitido incrementar
el número de profesionales que se
dedican a esta actividad que ha
permitido incrementar los recursos
económicos que ellas pueden aportar en
sus familias debe de servirnos de
ejemplo a todos en general en todos los
países del mundo para que todos estemos
dispuestos a dar esa batalla y a [ __ ]
ese tren es el tren de la
profesionalidad es el tren que nos
permite tener en cuenta todos los
aspectos medioambientales
y hacer una extracción controlada de los
recursos pero sin olvidarnos de los
aspectos sociales y económicos porque
todo ese aprovechamiento que nosotros
hacemos del mar tiene que repercutir de
manera directa en la sociedad de la que
formamos parte tiene que ser capaz de
generar nuevos puntos de riqueza
buscando nuevos puntos de trabajo y
generando a su vez una economía estable
para las sociedades costeras digo bien
claro y bien alto la actividad pesquera
no es una actividad que contribuya a
destrozar nuestro medio ambiente a
destrozar nuestro mar no todo lo
contrario la actividad pesquera es una
actividad que contribuye a la
recuperación de los ecosistemas marinos
y en esa línea desde luego nos queda un
trabajo muy fuerte por hacer pero como
bien digo no depende única y
exclusivamente de aquellos profesionales
que se dedican a la actividad pesquera
depende del conjunto de la sociedad
porque todos buscamos en el mar una
fuente de la que obtener beneficios ya
sean simplemente desde el punto de vista
turístico
no podemos olvidar que al mar vamos
todos no solamente los que realizamos
una actividad profesional al mar van
también las grandes compañías que se
dedican a extraer recursos de ese mar
bien sea en forma de energía o en forma
de determinados elementos como puede ser
la extracción de minerales o la
extracción de cualquier tipo de residuos
que también afectan al ecosistema por lo
tanto es un reto de futuro es un reto de
sociedad es un reto para toda la
humanidad el poder contribuir para que
nuestro planeta siga siendo azul y que
en ese planeta azul todos busquemos un
elemento de futuro porque el mar nos lo
da todos y todos somos capaces de
contribuir a que el mar siga siendo vivo
así es que yo simplemente pongo un reto
para todos los biólogos marinos que
sigan estudiando cómo están nuestros
recursos como va variando nuestro
nuestro ecosistema y que esa información
que obtienen todos los científicos
aquellos que nos dedicamos a la gestión
de las políticas públicas
utilizarlos en el bien de rem regular
todas las explotaciones que se puedan
hacer en el entorno del mar como bien
digo no solamente las que tienen que ver
con el ámbito pesquero sino con todos
los ámbitos de sociedad es un reto
ilusionante es un reto apasionante y es
un reto que nos debe de llevar a todos
los que vivamos o no directamente del
mar a trabajar por él porque eso nos
dará desde luego un mejor planeta en el
que seguir viviendo y en el que seguir
haciendo futuro
[Música]